supernatural has a fandom second to none
millions love the dark fantasy series
and the actors who are part of it but
where was the cast before all of this
fame
let's uncover some of the roles of the
supernatural stars before they were
slaying demons and raising hell
before jensen ackles was saving people
and hunting monsters on supernatural
he already had a variety of credits to
his name the texas native's first big
break came on the long-running soap
opera days of our lives
he played eric brady for 54 episodes
ackles also had a recurring guest role
on the biggest teen drama of the new
millennium
dawson's creek he left the world of
soaps behind in 2000 for a significant
role in james cameron's tv series dark
angel
the two-season fox show familiarized him
with the world of sci-fi which he
continued to explore in a 22-episode arc
on smallville where he played assistant
football coach jason teague
while fans can't possibly imagine ackles
as anyone but the scruffy older
winchester brother
he actually tried out for sam before
snagging his iconic role as dean
before jared patalecki started slaying
demons as sam winchester the actor
played
dean forrester rory gilmour's first love
on gilmore girls
he was part of the show from the 2000
pilot through 2005.
so both ackles and padalecki had a
working relationship with the wb
turned cw network prior to landing their
respective supernatural roles
in 2004 patalecki starred in the mary
kate and ashley olsen film new york
minute
playing the love interest to mary kate's
character roxy
stepping away from his more comedic
roles padalecki then played john davis
in the desert island film flight of the
phoenix
right before his supernatural debut he
starred as wade in the horror film house
of wax
a part that prepared him for his career
as a ghoul hunter in the creeptastic
world of supernatural
action horror romance this is one actor
who's done it all
misha collins brought a boatload of new
fans to supernatural upon making his
season 4 debut as castiel
before that he made his mark on
hollywood with a range of roles
between his portrayal of alexis drazen
on 24 to
appearing in procedurals like csi crime
scene investigation
er ncis csi new york and without a trace
collins kept plenty busy he also starred
with laura prepon
in carla his most regrettable film to
date collins played serial killer paul
bernardo
collins told fans to avoid the movie
happily collins himself is nothing like
the character having started the charity
random acts
and running gishwhes a hugely popular
charitable international scavenger hunt
before jeffrey dean morgan literally
made head's role as negan on the walking
dead he played sam
and dean's revenge driven father on
supernatural
but even before that the actor already
had a host of acting credits to his name
yet morgan didn't always dream of being
an actor
unlike most hollywood origin stories
acting basically fell into morgan's lap
when he helped a friend move to los
angeles
following his debut as sharky in uncaged
morgan went on to appear in tv series
like walker texas ranger
er csi crime scene investigation star
trek enterprise
monk the oc and weeds that's a lot of
guest star roles
his movie credentials are just as vast
but acting isn't morgan's only passion
he and friend paul rudd co-owned samuel
sweet shop in rhinebeck new york
the duo saved the shop from closure when
the owner passed in 2014.
morgan told jimmy fallon he passed away
suddenly
and we didn't want the story to be
anything else than what it was when
samantha smith took on the role of mary
winchester on supernatural
she likely expected her first week on
set to be her last
not many characters who die in the pilot
episode end up coming back after all
especially not ones who get burned to
death yet smith's warm and compelling
performance as mama winchester cemented
her as a fan favorite and the writers
kept finding new ways to write her back
into the show
but before she brought the og winchester
hunter to life and death smith had a
vast number of acting credits to her
name in the early 90s
she scored tv roles in seinfeld pacific
blue
friends and two of a kind she then
kicked off the 2000s with her role as
kate wilton
on profiler jim beaver's performance as
bobby singer a surrogate father to the
winchester brothers resonated
immediately with many fans
however before beaver donned a wardrobe
of plaid and baseball caps to hunt
monsters
he had already amassed a whole slew of
acting credits
before beaver became an actor he entered
the us marine corps just after his high
school graduation in 1968. following his
return to the u.s beavers scored his
first acting role in 1977 on semi-tough
for the next three decades he guest
starred in a multitude of tv shows
including matlock reasonable doubts nypd
blue and third rock from the sun
he also earned significant roles in
shows like the young and the restless
and days of our lives
not long after a stint on the show the
ranch beaver starred in deadwood from
2004 to 2006 ending shortly after his
run
on supernatural began supernatural has
brought a lot of couples together
one particularly prominent duo emerged
when then genevieve cortessi was cast as
ruby in season four
she and jared padilecki sam ended up
finding love in a demonic place
today they are married with three
children but before the couple was
canoodling on screen or in real life
genevieve padilecki earned a bundle of
acting credits
the actress had stints on death valley
the dead zone kids in america
and salted nuts beginning in 2004 a year
later genevieve landed a 51-episode lead
role in the tv series wildfire
while jensen ackles and d'neill ackles
formerly harris didn't find love on the
supernatural set
she was a late addition to season 13 she
plays sister joe
a vapid angel disguised as a healer
prior to her arc on supernatural denial
had significant guest spots on tv series
like one life to live
what i like about you and joey the
friend spin-off
danielle's biggest claim to fame was her
role as rachel in 51 episodes of the cw
teen drama one tree hill though jansen
and denial had previously met their
relationship bloomed after they starred
in the indie film 10-inch hero
the film chronicles the lives of
sandwich shop workers featuring a
delightfully feminist denial as priestly
following this film denial played a few
small roles on various tv shows before
landing a larger part in the short-lived
show friends with benefits as far as
movies are concerned she had parts
in the back-up plan the roommate and a
very herald and kumar christmas
before felicia day played charlie
supernatural's hacker turned hunter the
actress had already carved out a
significant corner of the nerd culture
sphere
though she'd had a few small prior roles
her eight-episode arc as vi on the
seventh season of buffy the vampire
slayer put her on the map
day went on to star and bring it on
again and had a variety of smaller roles
in shows like monk
and undeclared she landed her second
joss whedon project in 2008 when she
played penny in the cult classic dr
horrible's
sing-along blog in 2007 day created the
guild
a web series inspired by day's love of
world of warcraft
they even created a music video for the
project do you want to date my avatar
which riffs off the idea of becoming an
idealized and often
unattainable version of yourself online
from 2009 to 2010
day appeared in two episodes of a third
whedon project
dollhouse did you catch this classic
line from dean in the episode lucifer
rising
how about this the sweet life of zach
and cass
the show's playful pun was to honor kim
rhodes then a new guest star who starred
on the disney channel show
the suite life of zack and cody from
2005 to 2008
but before either role the actress had a
long list of acting credits to her name
rhodes first made waves as cindy in
another world a character she played
again
in as the world turns from there she
landed a series of guest roles in shows
like martial law
star trek voyager touched by an angel
without a trace and csi crime scene
investigation
a year before her stint on the suite
life of zack and cody rhodes had a small
role in christmas with the cranks
rob benedict richard spright jr and matt
cohen made a splash at conventions
together back around supernatural season
5.
rob benedict's band loudon swain has
since become
a staple at conventions and no one
throws a costumed karaoke shindig like
sprite jr and cohen
benedict and sprite jr even created a
series together called kings of khan in
which they chronicle convention
shenanigans often alongside cohen
but where were they before they became
supernatural icons
spray junior came on to the acting scene
in 1984 earning spots on tv movies and
series including er
running the halls and freddy's
nightmares later he earned roles in
shows like band of brothers
the agency and jericho like day benedict
had a stint on buffy the vampire slayer
but instead of playing a slayer
benedict played a vampire the actor also
played significant roles in felicity
birds of prey
come to papa and threshold before
snagging the role of chuck
aka god on supernatural prior to his
2008 supernatural episode cohen launched
his acting career in 2005 with tv movie
and series roles including how to get
away with murder
south of nowhere and medium you can't
have lucifer without crowley and you
can't have mark pellegrino without mark
shepard
before the duo's battle for the title of
king of hell however shepard and
pellegrino
enjoyed vibrant careers in hollywood
launching his acting career in 1987
pellegrino's big break was playing billy
phelps in lethal weapon 3.
from there he went on to projects like
midnight witness the big lebowski
and a murder of crows by the 2000s
pellegrino had already amassed dozens of
roles
going on to appear in four episodes of
nypd blue and eight of dexter
before taking on lucifer before signing
on to supernatural in 2009 most fans
probably recognized mark shepard from
his appearances on like-minded shows
including charmed
star trek voyager and firefly shepard
got his start before those series
however in 1992 as eddie bryce in the tv
series
silk stockings he went on to appear in
20 episodes of soldier of fortune
and had numerous roles in shows like
sliders 24 and battlestar galactica
supernatural has gone through more than
its fair share of major guest stars but
few have made quite as big of a splash
as
alexander calvert who plays jack the son
of satan
calvert won fans over instantly amassing
a sea of immediate jack stands
but before supernatural the actor got
his start in 2005 with a small role
in the dead zone his career immediately
took off earning him guest roles on
shows like psych
the troop and bates motel he went on to
play larger roles in arrow and the movie
edge of 17 before landing jack
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one